[Music]
good morning everybody
is officially the end of winter break I
guess we went out with the bang last
night why did I decided I tried
finishing this gin I think I have a bit
of a hangover there first things first I
don't know if we've update you guys
along the way but Isaac no longer likes
eating the sandwiches for lunch he likes
eating hot foods for lunch and we've
been bought like thermoses and stuff for
him but I don't know what the thermoses
are oh dear oh dear
so Isaac did not empty the contents of
his lunch box after the last day of the
school it's been two weeks since he's
been at school oh my god oh my goodness
miss stuff traps like this thing is like
airtight so it oh dear we are making it
on this morning so Isaac you're tired of
eating sandwiches right cold sandwiches
are boring yeah so you've opted to do
the thermos hmm
but what are the stuff though that's the
last warm you got to go to school 7:30
Isaac usually packs pasta and he makes
his own pasta sometimes sometimes we do
chili beef stew and today we're gonna do
if I knew thermoses were a thing growing
up I probably would have done the same
thing too because I not a big fan of
cold sandwiches and school food to get
the old
[Music]
so now the dope is quite about doing the
Sudan stuff for Isaac my mom recently
came over she introduced a new system
for us to start doing for ourselves and
that is if we were to have hot pot or
shabu-shabu for dinner and we had
leftover shabu meat what she likes to do
is to wrap the shabu shabu me and she
wrapped it right back into the its own
wrapping but she likes to freeze these
things and she pre packages it in
perfect amount that you would want for
eating instant noodles for instant hutan
I just did with a quick lunch
so she pre packs everything and then
like a certain number of slices I
thought that was really cool and she did
this for us and I think we'll start
doing this on here on out
[Music]
being an Asian dude this is a really big
lunch and I love Bhutan I love hot
noodles the broth a little bit of slices
of meat that is my jam
I'm not a big sandwich by myself so I
totally get it
this thing keeps it hot oh wait that's
guys think I'm like was it hot bring a
lunch yeah it's really really hot are
you ready for alright so I just dropped
up Isaac at school and this whole
morning I was I've been thinking the
back of my mind back in my head like
what am I gonna do with my day and like
be productive and I realized on top of
vlogging this vlog I should probably
make a cooking video because that's
something I've been trying to promise
you guys cuz I don't know like there's a
few you guys not that I really enjoy my
cooking videos and I really appreciate
that and I love cooking and I love food
and always like to share things I like
to cook the way I make it and so there
is one recipe I feel like I really need
right now I don't know when I drink too
much like I get these like squashes like
the splotches spots it probably looks
like it's part of my freckles I have a
lot of freckles on my face too but it's
not it's like these like little red
bruising stuff happening on my face and
not quite sure why that happens if you
happen to know please let me know yeah
hangover cure
bottom line might as well make the
ultimate Chinese hangover cure in my
opinion and that would be Joe hey Kay
kanji and probably do a chicken congee
like with like century egg kind of
combat combination I don't know some
like really classic cantonese at home
styles
[Music]
I'm just gonna highlight this little
contraption that dad got for me for the
holidays and it is a mocha pot for
making coffee it's better than a French
press which is how I usually make my
coffee if I'm in a rush I used to Keurig
but he was saying this is an ideal way
to make coffee if you want the best
tasting coffee get a mocha pot had no
idea what that was he was like you
should get it on Amazon we primed it we
did Amazon Prime got here in two days
and we started drinking coffee from this
and hands-down probably one of the
better coffee makers I have ever used
and it's really cool so this is how it
works so we got the one initial water
that goes in through here this is where
the coffee grounds go yeah coffee goes
there we put this on the stove turn up
the heat water gets boiling and steams
through the coffee grinds into this
piece thick twists on top of that and
you have your coffee in there pretty
dope
[Music]
but it actually makes an actual espresso
because the pressure the steam pushes up
through the coffee grind so it's not a
drip coffee and the coffee is really
really strong and then yeah you want
some of that - mm-hmm
this video you're watching will not have
the cooking recipe in this video be a
separate like actual cooking video a
standalone video so make sure to
subscribe and stay tuned for that video
[Music]
all right it is time to start cooking
making that kanji healing this hangover
be on the lookout for this video
I'm excited to share it with you it's
like the Chinese version of like
grandma's chicken noodle soup after a
couple of hours of cookin I want to show
you guys the progress so far there's the
kanji playing kanji with some chicken
broth and some my favorite century egg
and I've marinated the chicken here and
that's gonna go in there
and just a few I'm gonna take a break
from all this right here post a YPO over
there that's brought home some Jersey
Mike's how is your facial
beautiful gorges some extraction when
they like they do like a little like
puncture over the skin and then like
push the gunk out how so I think she did
one here and like somewhere over here so
it's kind of like what you do when
you're with your fingernails and you put
your fingers together when you do that
you actually break the skin open so this
way it's like a nice like clean like
puncture instead of like breaking with
skins because when you break the skin
and you pop it like that you end up
causing scars yeah yeah here's like a
pop so cuz I have my top but then it's
like also a micro dermabrasion facial
okay so it's like he's like tiny little
head that kind of like I don't know like
scrub your skin or something and it's
like a suction I don't know but I like I
get it once a month with my girl cherry
for them anyway we got eaten launched
the worst thing about making cooking
videos is it smells so good in here but
because of the camera and all that stuff
it slows down the cooking time and you
want to make everything look like more
camera friendly I guess - and so you end
up just never never really eating the
food you're making I'm gonna be
you can't even have a lot done true a
good chef I guess should keep this
station clean at all times that kind of
crap but and when I cook I just do it
really fast it's a huge like mess when
I'm cooking it but when I'm you know
making the videos I tried to make the
countertop in the workspace look nicer
so it's been a lot of time cleaning
everything in between steps and
everything just gets drawn out super
long yeah actually that would be a lot
easier I have a really shaky head
everybody honestly doesn't look like
much but it this is so flavorful
actually it could be a lot more
flavorful
I cut one corner in particular that I
shouldn't have without getting fed up
with the whole camera and stuff like
that actually cut corners like my
cooking videos you just go all out and I
never do but UH one thing was marinating
the chicken I did not add ginger and
garlic I just used soy sauce salt sesame
oil and white pepper and this it's
really missing that garlic flavor and
yeah well
[Music]